the only thing that can be short of
about the future is it will be
absolutely my name is Jenna eigen broad
I'm a scientist at NASA Goddard Space
Flight Center and I was here to talk
about the discovery of organic matter on
Mars I always loved science when I was
in school I think it was even middle
school that I like science classes and
it really was just sort of fostered by
my family and friends to not stop asking
questions I think my mom was pretty
patient with me when I asked why all the
time one day I came home and tried to
explain the weather it were at least
predicted based on the cloud I remember
that
you know I've always been kind of
fascinated with nature and science
really just stuck with me but the same
time I also loved art I've always liked
painting and making things and for a
long time I thought I was going to
explore an art career and at some point
I realized that to be the scientist I
wanted to be I had to apply my
creativity to science instead and since
then I've realized that the imagination
that's needed to understand and discover
things is pretty astounding and other
people with it always amaze me so
there's as much creativity in science as
there ever has been in art I would say
so I think I made the right choice
imagination to me is thinking of things
that we haven't thought about before
some people would say thinking outside
the box of what we're familiar with
imagining something that's so different
than what we have ever seen or anyone
else has ever showed us in their own
imagination it's something new it's kind
of its own describe areas but it's very
personal but in science you ground it in
data you have to actually have
observations to change your perspective
of something then you're gonna imagine
what that data means and when you come
up with an idea of how to explain the
data we're using their imagination
that's the hypothesis that's the next
one we go to explore its and test and
then the new results come in and they
inform us about something and then you
use your imagination to figure out the
bigger picture what does that mean
the next hypothesis is generated this is
how science evolves this is how we've
gone from understanding one small bit of
the world and other worlds to having a
better understanding of the whole thing
Mars is a red planet and it's seemingly
inactive at least from a distance and
there's all this evidence that suggests
that things were active on the plan at
one point we knew all this or at least
this was the general perspective before
curiosity landed and then where we
landed and we're driving along and we
find this rock that has a whole bunch of
smaller pebbles in it and they're
rounded and they're different sizes and
our first thought was we found a
conglomerate that is deposited from a
river it's something we find on earth
all the time but we had to take a couple
steps back wait a second
are we sure there was water is water
what moved those rocks and what rolled
them and turned them into rounded little
pebbles something had to take an angular
rock something with sharp edges and
knock them all off to make rounded
pebbles there's a whole bunch of
different sizes what process made that
we kind of went back and reviewed the
actual physics of different types of
materials and media that might
actually create this to make sure that a
river matched up with that because the
processes that were happening on Mars
may not have been the same as what we
had on earth so we had to like kind of
go back to first principles how did we
figure out on earth that a conglomerate
was made by a river or in river
processes let's do the same on Mars okay
what did it take to do that and did we
arrive at the same conclusion we did but
we had to go back to first principles
and make sure we understood all of that
before we could be confident in that
conclusion and then it was oh my gosh
there was rivers on Mars
okay just think about that for a moment
Weald are a red planet and we had
evidence of a river on Mars for the
first time wow talk about fueling your
imagination what is today is not was in
the past
was something completely different and
then when we drilled into the rocks and
we found grey material and realized
there's just red dust everywhere it's
this rust that's all it's iron rust
the whole planets not red that's just
the surface there's something else
hidden underneath all of that and we're
still figuring out what that is I think
I think that is absolutely fascinating
because the challenge is a lot of our
science scientific understanding those
rocks are grey and parts of them turned
red later so what's the story for the
grey rock that's all over the place what
is that that's all we're going to keep
exploring and find out
I helped to put Sam in the operation and
figure out processing of the data so
that we can interpret it one of the big
things that I did was when I first got
to Goddard I was asked to help figure
out how do we calibrate the instrument
once we get the Mars and there's this
little cell on it it's actually no
bigger than the tip of my thumb I like
the size of a thimble and in that we
have a combination of gases and organic
molecules and I had to figure out what
to put in there as a calibrate for all
of the different types of experiments we
intended to do and I had come from
academics I had no idea what I was doing
here I was engineering something that
was critical for the science but I tell
you when the rover launched from Cape
Canaveral and you're looking at this
giant rocket and the very very tippy top
has the rover in it you can barely see
the tippy-top and there's a rover and
they're inside the rover is to say I'm
instrument inside the Sam instrument is
a little I worked on that and it
laughter works and I'll tell you that is
the coolest thing that's a that was a
very special moment and then we used it
once we got the Mars and it was very
important for a lot of the work that we
did the biggest surprise was discovering
that there was evidence of macro
molecules made of carbon these are big
molecules most all natural organic
matter that we find anywhere whether
it's earth biology in meteorites most of
it as macromolecules but we didn't
really expect not everyone expected to
find any evidence of organic matter at
the surface of Mars but the find
evidence of macromolecules gives us a
clue as to how they were preserved and
actually lasted a three and a half
billion
years as they were deposited and all of
the radiation that happened over tens of
millions of years which destroys
organics when we started this mission
most of the people in the science team
did not think we were actually going to
find evidence of organic matter not in
the samples that we were collecting so
to find what we did really makes us all
do a about-turn and changes our
understanding of what's possible
especially when we think about what we
might study in the future if there's
organic molecules preserved at the
surface there most certainly must be
organic molecules preserved deeper down
and they probably preserve the
information that we seek what's it from
is it from a meteorite
it's from geology is it from biology
that's the next big question there's so
much momentum behind this endeavor it's
international there's so many people who
want to see it happen it almost has a
life of its own it's going to happen so
we are working towards NASA is working
towards making that happen there's a lot
of questions that come with that
including science questions and so I'm
I'm very eager to help formulate what
science we will do before we send humans
and once humans are there
the only thing they can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]